okay has anyone else noticed that your
for you page has been a little too
accurate lately it hasn't been things
that i'll google or i talk about it's
been thoughts tick tock knows everything
about us hold up don't scroll let me ask
you something first can someone please
explain how this algorithm works tick
tock users often wonder how the world's
fastest growing social network seems to
know them so well tick tock's secretly
listening to us while we're watching
videos i don't know
the answer to how this app gets to know
you so intimately is a highly secretive
algorithm
long guarded by tick tock's china-based
parent company bite dance tik-tok has
been so successful in terms of
implementing their algorithm the tick
tock's algorithm can influence the
thinking of u.s
youth to understand how it knows users
so well the wall street journal created
over a hundred automated tick tock
accounts or bots that watched hundreds
of thousands of videos on the app we
also spoke to current and former
executives at the company officially the
company says that shares likes
follows and what you watch all play a
role in what tick tock shows you
we found that tick tock only needs one
of these to figure you out how long you
linger over a piece of content
every second you hesitate or re-watch
the app is tracking you just want to
quiet the noise through this one
powerful signal tick-tock learns your
most hidden interests and emotions
and drives you deep into rabbit holes of
content that are hard to escape
oh just a happy happy the tick tock
experience starts the same way for
everyone
open the app and you'll immediately see
an endless string of videos in your for
you feed
take this new user a 24 year old from
henry county kentucky
tick tock starts by serving the account
a selection of very popular videos
vetted by app moderators is this person
religious because i still have a purpose
and you still hold a plan for my life
do they want to participate in viral
dances
are they feeling down lately just
remember
i loved you once
and that love goes for a friend family
or any relationship
what tick tock doesn't know is that the
24 year old from kentucky isn't a person
at all
it's one of the bot accounts programmed
by the wall street journal let's call it
kentucky 96.
we set up these accounts to understand
how tick tock figures out your
unexpressed interests
we assigned each bot a date of birth and
an ip address
which told tiktok their location
none were given a gender
we gave each bot or user interests but
those interests were never entered into
the app
the only way our users expressed their
interests was by re-watching or pausing
on videos with related hashtags or
images
some were into extreme sports
others were interested in forestry
or dance
or astrology i'm not the babysitter i'm
not the parent or some other topic keep
scrolling if you hate animals
for all our accounts we found that tick
tock draws users in at first by serving
a wide variety of videos many with
millions of views
then as the algorithm sees what you
respond to the selection of videos and
the view counts can get lower and lower
with fewer of them vetted by moderators
to see if they violate tick tock's terms
of service
we reviewed our experiment and its
results with a data scientist an
algorithm expert and guillaume chaslow a
former google engineer who worked on
youtube's algorithm
he's now an advocate for algorithm
transparency he says tiktok is different
from other social media platforms the
algorithm on tick tock can get much more
powerful and it can be able to learn
your vulnerabilities much faster in fact
tick tock fully learned many of our
accounts interests in less than two
hours
summit figured out in less than 40
minutes
on youtube more than 70 of the views
come from the recommendation engine so
it's already huge but on tick tock it's
even worse
it's probably like 1995
of the content
that is seen that comes from the
recommendation engine
this is a visualization made from
hashtags attached to the videos our bots
watched
think of it as a partial view of the
universe of tick-tock content
here's where we find dance videos
over here are the cooking videos
the spindly arms stretching out of the
center represent niche content areas
this arm starts with general videos of
cute animals
but if we follow it out to the end we
find more specific videos for
enthusiasts of french bulldogs
as kentucky 96 starts its journey it
starts moving around within the
mainstream where tick tock is trying to
puzzle out what it wants
we programmed kentucky 96 to be
interested in sadness and depression
let's see how long it takes tiktok to
figure that out
life doesn't happen to you life happens
for you so if life is taking people away
from your life
and putting new ones in
less than three minutes into using
tick-tock at its 15th video kentucky 96
pauses on this
and that love goes for a friend family
or any relationship kentucky 96 watches
the 35 second video twice
here tick tock gets its first inkling
that perhaps the new user is feeling
down lately whatever comes let them come
whoever stays let them stay whoever goes
let them go the information contained in
this single video provided the app with
important clues
the author of the video the audio track
the video description
the hashtags
after kentucky96's first sad video tick
tock serves another one 23 videos later
or after about four more minutes of
watching i'll leave you alone from now
on if that's what you want
this one is a breakup video with the
hashtag sad
[Music]
still trying to suss out this new user
with more high view count videos
does the new user want to watch videos
about friendship
[Music]
or to laugh at funny fail videos
[Music]
nobody's gonna know they're gonna know
or do they like videos about home
repairs
[Music]
other information from your phone
including location can impact the videos
that are shown in a user's feed it has a
kentuckian i never thought i'd lose my
freedom over a virus
for instance kentucky 96 saw lots about
kentucky but whether or not it keeps
showing you that type of video depends
on your response to it a tick tock
spokeswoman said the app does not listen
to your microphone or read text messages
to serve you personalized videos
at video 57 kentucky 96 keeps watching a
video about heartbreak and hurt feelings
[Music]
and then at video 60 watch is one about
emotional pain
[Music]
based on the videos we watched so far
tick-tock thinks that maybe this user
wants to see more about love breakups
and dating
so at about 80 videos and 15 minutes in
the app starts serving more about
relationships
but kentucky 96 isn't interested your
voice your smile your eyes your love
the user instead pauses on one about
mental health
[Music]
then quickly swipes past videos about
missing an ex i miss you and i like
having you around
advice about moving on and how to hold a
lover's interest he spends more time on
his phone when he's around you kentucky
96 lingers over this video containing
the hashtag depression something's wrong
with me
[Music]
and these videos about suffering from
anxiety
[Music]
it's like a reward
after 224 videos into the bot's overall
journey or about 36 minutes of total
watch time
tick tock's understanding of kentucky 96
takes shape
videos about depression and mental
health struggles outnumber those about
relationships and breakups
from here on kentucky 96's feed is a
deluge of depressive content
93 of videos shown to the account are
about sadness or depression
people been looking at me i'm just like
what you looking at a tic toc
spokeswoman said that some of the
remaining seven percent of videos are to
help the user discover different content
but for kentucky 96 such videos were few
and far between the majority of videos
it was shown outside of its depressive
rabbit hole were ads
a tick-tock spokeswoman said that the
simulated activity generated by the wall
street journal's bots is not
representative of real user behavior
because humans have a diverse set of
interests
but even some of our accounts with
diverse interests
rabbit hold
we showed our data and many of the
videos seen by kentucky 96 to shazlow
what we see on tik tok is a bit the same
that what we saw on youtube so basically
the algorithm is detecting that this
depressing content
is useful to create engagement and
pushes depressing content so the
algorithm is pushing people towards more
and more extreme concerns so it can push
them toward more and more
watch time
tik-tok also says it allows you to see
less of something by selecting the not
interested button but chaslow says
that's not enough
the algorithm is able to find the piece
of content that you're vulnerable to
that will make you click that will make
you watch
it doesn't mean you really like it and
that's the content that you're
you enjoy the most it's just the content
that's the most likely
to make you stay on the platform
our bots only escaped rabbit holes when
we changed their viewing interests when
we told one bot to stop watching videos
about adhd the algorithm cut back on
that content
still many of the journal's bots were
rapidly pushed deep into rabbit holes
tick tock learned our bot's most
far-flung interests like astrology
but even bots with general mainstream
interests got pushed to the margins as
their recommendations got more
personalized and narrow
bots with an interest in sexual content
wound up way out here watching hashtag
king talk videos about sexual power
dynamics
and are bought with a general interest
in politics
wound up being served videos about
election conspiracies and q another
businesses
impeach biden and kamala
it goes from the house to the senate
deep in the niche worlds of tiktok users
are more likely to encounter potentially
harmful content
that is less vetted by moderators and
violates the app's terms of service
make them angry and sad they would be so
much happier without you a tick tock
spokeswoman said that the company
catches a lot of banned content which
passes through both computer analysis
and human moderators it also reviews
videos reported by users
don't tell them goodbye
[Music]
there's a lot of fun silly and
life-affirming content on tock
but while tick tock can draw out what
makes you laugh
it can also make you wallow in your
darkest thoughts turning the pain from
mental to physical work without ever
needing to eavesdrop on you or collect
any personal information about you i've
never attempted suicide or anything
i've never let it get that far
whether it's on tick tock on facebook on
youtube we're interacting with algorithm
in our everyday life more and more
we are training them
and they are training us
so we have to study this so we
understand it better and we don't let it
go in directions
that are harmful to society or to
certain groups of people
[Music]